oo how much work did I put into it so
again it was pilot season and I got the
script and I remember reading it and
doing it in an American accent and
thinking that sounds wrong when I was
auditioning for Stuff I'd meet up with a
friend of mine who was also an actor and
he had stuff to do as well we talk about
the material I I had this script I said
I've got this feeling about this that
the way that it's written the Cadence of
it and all that it really reminded me of
like n coward's writing or Oscar wild
and that kind of like high style thing
and so I started messing around with
that notion and he's like that's it
that's that's how you should play this
character um do you give him money from
each I don't I just give him a lot of
love